one of Hollywood's biggest directors
Quentin Tarantino is coming clean about
what he knew about Harvey Weinstein
Tarantino admits he has known for
decades about Weinstein's alleged sexual
misconduct with women he tells New York
Times correspondent and CBS News
contributor Jody Kanter that he feels
ashamed for doing nothing the two men
have been close for decades
most of Tarantino's movies like Pulp
Fiction and Kill Bill were distributed
by Weinstein Weinstein denies engaging
in any non-consensual sex
Jody Kanter is here good morning good
morning it's been two weeks about since
your piece came out now we have more
than 50 women have come forward and the
story is not done yet
I mean we're still every day there seems
to be a new disclosure yesterday Lupita
Nyong'o published an extraordinary essay
in The Times where she talked about a
very familiar now tale of alleged
harassment by Weinstein and what she
says is that she at the time didn't know
that it was happening to other women she
felt so alone so I think part of the
reason the story is staying alive is
that women keep coming forward and each
tale is so powerful the most how Branagh
seems always would be the same well in
her case what what is remarkable about
her story is that it took place in his
own kinetic at home and apparently his
children were just a rumor too away 30
life is hood of a criminal indictment in
some of these cases I don't want to
speculate too much on that these are
still allegations and we know that
police departments in several places are
investigating but I think it's the right
question to ask certainly Jodi the first
time you're on this at the table with
the story and we asked you is there more
to come you said we'll see did you know
that this was coming did you have any
inkling that this would be the follow-up
to your story I knew that there were
people in Hollywood who were waiting to
see whether they wanted to speak out or
not I never anticipated something like
the me2 movement which has now spread to
other industries and it's been
international and I think what's
happened part of the power of the
Weinstein story is that there are now
many people who are asking themselves
should I have said something 10 15 20
years ago for the victims it's very hard
we don't want to blame the victims I
think it would not do you know something
forward but yes but somebody like
Tarantino said to me specifically on the
phone to do
ago should I have done more I knew these
stories firsthand one of them happened
to my own girlfriend you know Mira
Sorvino I didn't take it seriously
enough i minimized it I brushed it aside
so I think many people are saying I
don't want to be the person whether I
was a victim or a witness or whatever I
don't want to brush it aside I want to
speak up and make sure that nobody else
has treated this way what should be the
conversation about sexual harassment
what should be the conversation well I
think that part of the conversation
we're having is that we still lack an
agreed-upon basic legal and social
definition of what sexual harassment is
one of the things that Quentin Tarantino
said to me is that when he heard the
stories from women he didn't think
sexual harassment he had a very
old-fashioned almost dismissive Jim egde
of oh the boss chased you know the
secretary around the desk a little bit
almost like it was some sort of comedic
set piece
he said that part of his recognition and
he he also said his culpability is the
fact that he now realizes that this was
a terrifying situation for women to be
in what do you make of the Weinstein
employees now speaking out you know it
was reported we just reported earlier
that many of them broke down and cried
when they read many of the revelations
that are coming forward that they had no
idea and now they want to be released
from their NDA's their non-disclosure -
well as a reporter I was thrilled that
they made that statement about NDA's
because I have said to many people on
the phone this summer and other times
NDA's should not be used to cover up
abuse you know we're journalists we
believe in people being able to tell the
story tell their stories I tell people
my job is to make it safe for you to
tell your story you know a piece of
paper is meant to you know prevent you
from leaking competitor secrets but not
to cover up abuse in the workplace the
Weinstein and Miramax company employees
are a really interesting case because
some of them did know and fail to speak
out years ago but a lot of people either
had no idea this was happening they just
went to work at these companies to make
films or remember that Weinstein and
Miramax executives and former executives
did help us in our reporting right
because our reporting became a way for
them to finally do
something after all these years they
didn't feel entirely right about what
had happened
Thank You Jodi thank you very much Jodi
Cantor thank you